he's the owner of attack athletics a
60,000 square foot training facility he
started as Michael Jordan's personal
trainer in 1989 and continued to do so
for the rest of his career he's built an
impressive resume of injury prevention
and rehabilitation for professional
athletes
he's Tim Grover and here are his top ten
rules for success well you know what we
in the book relentless we talk about the
don't think concept your skills are so
finely reef are good at what you do
whether it's trading making business
decisions playing basketball that you
know the net if you do fail at something
it's just this little stumbling block
the next time you're going to succeed
because you've done it over and over
over again not only physically but your
mental preparation the thing that makes
individuals really really special what
that great is they're always looking for
that competitive edge so it's
interesting to see how a champion in
sports how it relates to a champion in
business it's the same mindset it's
about winning the battles continuing to
improve learning new ways to stay ahead
stay ahead of the game
clarity is what gives you the idea of
success being able to close those deals
when you can see and you can think and
you can react with a clear mind and your
take your emotions out of it you're in
that zone getting the deal is just it's
just a byproduct and the minute you get
the deal you're already thinking about
what's next where you want to excel it
something what must you have did I just
hear somebody say passion in the
audience you know what passion is
passion is an emotion it's an emotion
without an action passion will get you
nowhere inner drive will get you nowhere
unless you act on it you have to act on
your passion you have to act on your
inner drive don't let those feelings
stay inside of you you got to know what
to do with them you got to know how to
make them work in order to get what you
want don't keep it inside knowing that
you are the best at what you do and
you've done all your homework to get to
that point
landless is about trusting your
instincts but the only way you can trust
your instincts is if you've done your
homework and your skill is so finely
tuned at whatever you do you have people
in sports you have the role players and
they're trying to step out and be
Superstars and I just I always tell them
I said you've got to think about winning
first all right if the team wins you'll
get paid if the team doesn't win you
will not get paid okay the bottom line
is the end result just like when you
guys close a deal not only do you win
everybody underneath you who helps you
close the deal the company it all ties
in together beside commit act succeed
repeat the one thing that all the greats
have in common is they sweat the small
stuff they pay very very close attention
to every detail Michael used to sweat
the details so much in his basketball
game that carried on into his personal
life the suit had to match the car he
was driving that particular day but what
those details allowed him to do was to
put him in the zone to be the best
basketball player on that given night
the dark side is something that's in
everybody but it's a situation that you
have to control the dark side if it
controls you that's when things start to
go real real bad that's when you have a
tendency to go to the what I call the
other side but if you harness the fuel
that's from that dark side whether it's
anger whether it's fear and turn that
into positive fuel it'll help you really
succeed at whatever you're trying to do
a great leader knows how to push buttons
how to push the buttons of different
people I totally disagree with that
philosophy 100% all right I don't want
to have somebody to have that much
control over me where they're pushing my
buttons as a great leader okay what I do
with my clients is I pull their buttons
and then I teach them in certain
situations to know when to push their
own buttons
well you have to keep yourself focused
on whatever your ultimate goal is there
stumble there stumbling blocks all the
way people get laid off you have a bad
game you get traded from a team that you
don't want to be with but if your goal
and you focus remains the same that hey
this is going to happen and I know I
have the skills and I have the knowledge
and have the instincts to dig myself out
of this hole you will dig yourself out
of the hole you have to control the
situation
don't let the situation control you talk
about coolers we talked about closers
and we talked about cleaners cleaner is
going to get you that end result over
and over again they are so well prepared
and their instincts are so sharp they
already know what to do if there's a
person that's producing exceptionally
there's a reason behind it it's the
process the constant challenge to get
there again and again and again is what
drives these individuals everyone talks
about we want to be legendary you want
to be iconic
don't settle for legendary thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because Jake Barcelona asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of Tim
grover's top ten rules had the biggest
impact for you leave it in the comments
I will join the discussion thank you so
much for watching get you to believe and
I'll see you soon